i think the mistake is that it says like
stuff instead of funny
things like this
and people also want the do you know
what you're sitting on i feel like i saw
a couple comments that said even though
we don't have the couch anymore we don't
have it let's uh and and feel free
maurice also to interact with our
audience what are some of the comments
yeah let's hear some comments okay
caroline brought them up so i don't know
if you want to bring them up on screen i
have them in front of me okay there's
one from master kush master kush yeah
cushion oh right here we go yeah he's uh
wheat he says lou is the fu to the
audience on behalf of howie
howie doesn't even laugh at lou's
attempts at jokes [ __ ] you master kush
right see so he was right master kush
whose jokes loose jokes ferment with you
guys
it's pop pot yeah yeah okay they they
really they marinate for a little while
and then about 17 or 18 years later you
go geez that was funny yeah luke could
uh could have been funny
had good timing had
and contributed to the show
coulda woulda shoulda this is a
reference
because you said you know the reference
you know what the reference is yeah
what's the joke it's one of your jokes
yes of course coulda woulda shoulda the
joke is
that
i could have been a sociopathic
psychotic
uh narcissist all right what is it
narcissism narcissist
coulda woulda shoulda coulda woulda
shoulda yeah why do we all know your
joke i don't know that's the thing
because they they sit with you
it took me 30 it took me 30 years to
figure out that mark f said i love that
the worse that worse lose jokes get the
more jackie laughs
all right i got one for you okay mr mark
f
sigurie is the way i pronounce disagree
you may siggery with that but let's
agree to ziggery
that's going to be another 30 years mark
f get writing buddy
okay lucifer is a whimper blank jackie
laughing at lou's comments is hilarious
even how he stares in disbelief that
should be a segment a whole segment on
his jokes you staring at disbelief and
me cracking up i believe this belief's
there dude what are you pointing at alex
what does it say
i just love that they call him lucifer
as lucifer as a barrel full of pickles i
enjoy his why did the bike fall over it
was
tired it was tired two tired jokes
that's not my joke that's not his joke
it was jimmy c's joke should it be
two-tiered
look at the next one what's the next one
and
lou
is unfortunately back he absolutely
ruins
every podcast how how he has him on
pound sign
fire exclamation exclamation
and then chris ryan five days ago pound
sign how old are you when his eyes make
me melt i can't
why did you put that in a bigger font i
can't that was paralyzed
that's so funny
i want to say that i'm very thrilled i
dodged any bullets on this guy not one
comment about you've never been on
before oh you might have all these past
comments yeah oh you think this is
happening i thought you were like at
least youtubing out to like somebody
youtubing out we have we have older
people on the podcast today so we're not
youtubing out uh pound sign wish this
was live
i don't know if you were streaming this
this is literally in a word document oh
okay got it this is what all right very
good oh okay go to chemo and bring that
this is get this is again the dang
okay the cat's pajamas joke was good got
to give him credit where credit is due
what's the cap pajamas joke the k i i i
saw a pair of cat's pajamas with bee's
knees they were [ __ ] awesome that was
a good one
can you imagine if that's how audience
responded
that was a good one
that's a convention of comics before we
read any more of these um there were a
whole bunch of comments about how much
everyone loves you or how you're i still
they're not fun to read i know they're
not as much fun to read but there are a
bunch of people that you know what we
just did
we just said they're not so the people
are giving good comments are just going
to tell them that they hate [ __ ]
losers
no i love the good ones thank you for
all the good comments okay put up one of
the reasons
this is perfect just once could lou just
not blew it
up
i've been saying that for 40 years
[Laughter]
you know uh um i just want to say that i
found out recently that less is more
it's and what's really funny about that
is i still call him less
do you get it
yeah yeah it's coming
it's coming
don't forget
it's kind of live if we look at today's
today no that's not true that's not
today's no can't be there you're not
youtubing out let's see let's see let's
see
these are new ones that none of us have
seen yet let's put up the the newest
ones let's see if they yeah i can't uh
lou had me laughing like crazy in this
episode that's what makes that's what
makes my tuesday every week that's what
dad's boy had me laughing like crazy in
this episode wow
i checked lou's twitter and he still has
the exact same amount of followers as in
the video
so you're not growing that's true i i
added a few oh yeah it's at luddinos at
ludwigia look at this adam wrote this is
just 44 minutes ago this came in adam
yeah oh yeah
read that the r right there the r and
lose r material
is for really really really really
really really really funny [ __ ] well
adam baby i got one for you i totally
yeah uh the next one what does it say
uh what is that noise prank calls for
quite a turn oh great material lou great
material you know let me just say this
for all you british people out there
that are listening
all right
bob is my uncle myron cotton nice what
did myron cotton say good one hi lou
that one didn't take me 40 years that
was good you like that one bob is my
uncle i like it are you the voice of any
other products that we uh are you want
what is that noise it's a cow what is
that
that was maurice lamarche that was my
breakfast
i was what is that noise are you guys
[ __ ] with us in there
alex
no it's not them it's not we're not
making any noise it's not me it's a
brony what is it
what is that noise it's my it's a brony
that i brought with you that was you no
it's maurice
no it's not it's not what is it make a
noise okay
what does a cow say maurice
well i actually stood next to a cow once
shooting aren't you the voice of lexus i
was the voice of lex what did alexis say
wow the 2016 lexus gs once driven
there's no going back see your lexus
dealer
yeah that's like but it's kind of creepy
so marie so i got an idea that's why
they dropped me and took on mindy driver
i got an idea for you although they
missed a perfect opportunity because the
austin mini people should have taken it
off because you do a lot of animated
stuff i have an idea for you what's your
idea it's an animation
an animation uh series about numbers
it's called the it's called the one that
got away
okay so anyway this is the show
[Music]